hi it's Michelle from loudmouth and
beauty science and today we're going to
be talking about hair more specifically
I'm going to be talking about what
olaplex is and how it works
olaplex is a brand that's been huge in
the hair world since it came onto the
market in 2014 it's the reason why my
hair is currently this dusty purple
color and still attached to my hair
after a single Asian 1/2 hour marathon
hair session it's pretty much
revolutionised hair bleaching and it's
formed a billion imitations there's
actually a lawsuit going on right now
over whether or not there's been an
infringement of ala plexus patent now
I'm not an employee of olaplex I'm not
being paid by olaplex I've never met
them I have nothing to do with them I'm
Jessica's medic science nerd and there's
a lot of cool science behind the product
let's get started
[Music]
olaplex is a brand of hair products that
contains a special active ingredient
that can join up the broken bonds in
hair it can be added to hair coloring
products to minimize damage or it can be
used as a separate repairing treatment
the active ingredient in these olaplex
products is called bizminer purple dye
glycol dye Meli age and it looks like
this
this little guy is the reason why old
flex works to restore hair that's been
damaged from too much bleaching too much
heat styling or just being beaten up
overtime but to understand how it works
we're going to have to have a closer
look at the structure of hair and what
happens when you bleach it if you've
ever looked at hair products you'll know
that the word protein is thrown around a
lot which makes sense because hair is
mostly made of protein it's mostly a
protein called keratin which you've
probably heard of before nails are made
of the same character as hair proteins
are really long chains of amino acids
and keratin contains a whole bunch of an
amino acid called cysteine which is
special because it contains sulfur atoms
which has the symbol s these sulfur
atoms can make two bonds and when
they're oxidized like from being exposed
to oxygen in the air they'll form bonds
with each other like this it's like
they're holding hands
these are called disulfide bonds because
they have two sulfur's sometimes they
also called cysteine inside the hair all
of these microscopic little disulfide
bonds join the hair together like glue
so you end up with really strong hair
this glue also sticks hair together and
gives it its shape whether it's curly or
straight
[Music]
the reason that natural hair is colored
is the melanin pigment which has a
structure which looks a bit like this
in chemistry this is called a conjugated
system with alternating double and
single bonds and this means that it's
really good at absorbing light black
hair for example absorbs all of the
colors of light but if you break this
conjugation the melanin pigment can't
absorb light anymore so it ends up
looking white within hair bleach there's
an alkali like ammonia and hydrogen
peroxide to break up the melanin but it
takes a bit of time for the bleaching to
work and because the bleach mixture is
serve reactive it can react with other
bits of your hair in the meantime such
as your strong keratin proteins in
practice after about half of the
disulfide bonds in your hair can be
broken during a severe bleaching session
normally if you expose your hair to
oxygen the sulfur sulfur bonds will
eventually form again but just to really
mess with your hair Hydra profs I can
actually cap off the sulfur so I can't
form these disulfide bonds again to mess
up your hair even more peroxide can also
react with other amino acids and it can
also break up the peptide bonds that are
joining each of the amino acids together
in your hair and so eventually you end
up with weak brittle damaged hair the
ingredient in olaplex which is this
amino purple dye glycol dime le8 can
actually join the sulfur atoms in your
hair back together again it reacts with
the sulfur atoms through a reaction
called a Michael addition and it acts as
a link between the two sulfur's the two
maleate ends of the olaplex complex
joined to a sulfur atom each and the
bizminer profil dye glycol part joins it
all together so you end up with joined
up sulphur atoms the really nifty thing
is that this reaction between the
olaplex ingredient and your hair happens
much faster than the reaction where
hydrogen peroxide caps off the sulfur
and stops it from reacting so when the
olaplex is mixed in with the hair bleach
and applied to hair it actually forms
these bridges and stops the capping
reaction from happening so the damage
during bleaching that's usually
irreversible isn't irreversible anymore
which is pretty cool it's so good at
preventing damage that my course black
Asian hair could be dyed to white in one
long sitting without it all breaking off
I can still hear style it I can gently
comb it while it's wet and it doesn't
break off when I brush it before olaplex
came along I wouldn't have been able to
get my hair to this color while leaving
it in a reasonable condition to make the
bleached hair even stronger there are a
few more steps of all effects still with
the same active ingredient in the same
mechanism of action after bleaching with
step one there step two which is applied
to your hair for 10 to 20 minutes after
the bleachers washed out this joins up
more of the cysteine sulfur atoms after
that there step 3 which is a take-home
treatment with a lower concentration of
olaplex which is applied for about 10 to
20 minutes again and then rinsed out
there's also a new shampoo and
conditioner imaginatively named 4 & 5
that also contain the same active
ingredient and they work the same way
[Music]
it isn't just bleaching that you can use
olaplex for it will work whenever broken
disulfide bonds are an issue which is a
lot of things pretty much all types of
hair damage will break sulfur sulfur
bonds for example if you use high ph
alkaline products like hair dye or high
pair shampoos if you have thermal damage
from using too much heat on your hair
like hair curlers and hair straighteners
and blow dryers if your hair gets
exposed to visible and UV light from the
Sun when you brush and style your hair
especially when it's wet and fragile you
can end up with lots of mechanical
damage this also happens if you
vigorously rub your hair dry with a
towel if you use other chemical
treatments on your hair like perming and
straightening in all of these cases and
olaplex hair treatment can help repair
the damage it will soften and strengthen
damaged hair and it can restore the
texture of natural curls you can even
use it to tame beards the bonds that the
olaplex forms in the hair are claimed to
be permanent and supposedly it won't
wash out but like the original disulfide
bonds they can still break so over time
your hair can still deteriorate in
conditions and that's all for today if
you want to find out more you can look
at the olaplex blog posts that i've
linked in the caption which has a bit
more detail about all of this if you
enjoyed this video I would really
appreciate it if you liked it and
subscribe to my channel you can also
find out more about the science behind
other beauty products in my blog and you
can follow me on Facebook and Instagram
for beauty science tips see you next
time for more beauty science
[Music]